[Music]
ryan steve congratulations you guys have
earned your spot in the final round of
this competition you came here you made
beautiful blades out of scraps and now
it's time to send you back to your home
for just to recreate this iconic weapon
from history
the nim-cha
pay attention to the details bladesmiths
we'll see you in four days
good luck come on
we're in omaha illinois it's raining
outside it's a good day to work in the
shop building our nimcha i'm going to
put the pullers in before i start
forging
[Music]
my point's going good got it pretty
close to what i want
my forge is not real long and while i'm
forging this blade it wants to warp i
don't think i accounted for the the
length of this blade and the weight the
ends want to hang out i've got a lot of
steel there a lot of stuff to manage
that's going to be the challenge to keep
that under control got my blade shaped
out pretty close to parameters so they
want in the books
[Music]
back in the home forge ready to start
beating out this nem chuck i've never
made anything this big i'm used to
making three to five inch skinners so
it's gonna be a difficult build to keep
it straight
i've chosen a piece of 5160 spring steel
i'm very familiar with it and it holds a
good edge
as i'm beveling this thing the natural
curve is coming into this metal making a
curve for me it flowed in and it just
worked out
i feel good at the end of day one my
blade is forged out parameters are met
on it tomorrow i just got to go in and
go full throttle
it's beginning of day two so we're gonna
get after it
working on my guard right now
trying to get a guard shaped out of a
railroad spike and uh using this old
hammer it needs some maintenance so
we're just gonna make it work the best
we can
[Music]
i think this belt's hitting this
flywheel knocking it off this got me
kind of behind the hammer just wasn't
performing like it should
oh i see that's what that is duct tape
throw some more tape on that
let's see
that seemed to work a lot better
end of day two i feel pretty good got my
guard done today got it fit up i'm
pretty happy with how it turned out
i'm pretty excited where i finished up
yesterday i got all the forging done
today i'm going to finish grinding and
put fullers in it and get it ready for
quenching
i'm gonna take a lot of the mass out but
i will leave some meat on the bone so it
doesn't warp or twist on me
everything's going smooth just like it's
supposed to now that the bevels are in
i'm ready to go into quench i'm a little
nervous about the quench being long
blade like it is there's a lot of things
that can go wrong
i didn't hear no tings or pings
i feel pretty good about it but we'll
have to look and see after it cools off
and we've got a straight blade
perfect
into day two i feel great i got the
blade quince i got the fullers put in it
it's turning out to be a beautiful blade
day three feel good
right now it's heat treat time
it's a little nerve wracking you put all
this work into something and it all
hinges on this one moment
[Music]
this is where things can go bad
uh-oh
cover it up with something
outside of the fireball in my face heat
tree went well i had some minor bends
and i think i can clean it up good on
the grinder
we're ready to start on the handle
tomorrow
today is day four and also it's my
birthday i've gotta finish cleaning the
guard up on it fit it put a pommel on it
my brain's running 100 mile an hour and
i can't figure out how to get this
pommel to stay
after i sat back i figured out how to do
it i threaded my tang and screwed my
palm along it's going to give enough
weight on the back side i think to
balance this blade out now that
everything's glued together and
everything's all constructed i go to
finish sharpening and polishing my blade
[Music]
now ready to test it and see what it's
going to do
in the day four and i feel great the
blade's done and i get a surprise
birthday party for my family that makes
me really happy just couldn't be a
better day i'm ready for competition
placements welcome to the kill test
it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage your nymphs will do i will
take your weapon delivers some lethal
blows on this more carcass
ryan you're up first you ready for this
make some barbecue cut all right let's
try
seeing the boar carcass i'm smiling from
ear to ear
i wanted to see him cut up four carcass
in half with it i know it's razor sharp
[Music]
good job
all right ryan i don't know what's a
bigger beast the boar carcass or your
nimcha right here
this is a heavy sword everything about
the weight that you have on this
allows for a very very deep cut but it's
a lot of work because of the weight it's
very forward heavy but overall
it will kill thank you all right steve
your turns are you ready yes sir let's
do this
i'm excited ryan's blade cut well so i
know i've got some competition here mine
better perform
okay
all right steve let's talk about your
nimcha right here
first up the handle construction
it's smooth it's not blocky so i like
that you have it all void over there and
it marries in
before i started testing
your blade had a little bit kick off to
the side
but after the test it stayed the same
your edge with a thinner profile like
that cuts deep also it is a much
lighter sword
than your competitors i can control with
every slash overall sir your blade feels
good
you will keel thank you sir
blade smith welcome to the strength test
the pillar and pop chop
to test the strength and durability of
your edge as well as the overall
construction of your nimchas i'll be
chopping into these pots and pillars
remember this test is all about where
the targets do to your blades and not
what your blades do to the target
brian you're up first you ready for this
tear it up all right man
i know i'm behind the eight ball right
now
i need to perform really well in the
strengthness test
hopefully i'll i'll pull back up in the
line with him and be evened up
well ryan in the strength test the edge
that you have on here took a slight roll
like i i can't see it so much as i can
feel it
the rest of it is is really wicked sharp
it's still all in one piece
nice job thank you steve you're up next
you ready for this yes sir all right
cool
i feel pretty good i think my blade cut
a little better than ryan's maybe but he
didn't have that cant and flaw in his
blade so i think i've got a blade
that'll hold up to it
[Music]
well steve i got a problem man
when i picked this sword up i was
excited it's nice light
got a good shape to it but looking at
your steel here
there's a really big grain in here you
really could have used more
thermocycling i'm guessing i don't know
how you uh how you heat treated this but
however you did it ended up brittle
[Music]
well steve your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure during our strength
test and can no longer continue with
testing therefore i'd like to invite you
to shake our hands shake your
competitor's hand and then please exit
the forge
congratulations
i'm disappointed my blade broke but i
didn't want to go out that way but it is
what it is
thank you i just must have got my heat
treat wrong nobody's fault but my own
i didn't win the competition but i i
gained so much more than i lost here i'm
on a walk away here with my head held
high and it's going to make me a better
blade smith board i've really learned a
lot
ryan congratulations you are the forge
and fire champion that is a title that
comes with a check go ahead you can
smile for ten thousand dollars brother
good job
come on man
good job thank you it's not how i wanted
to win this competition but you know
it is what it is
first thing i'm gonna do is hug and kiss
my wife and and love on the kids and
play with them and get right back in the
forge there's no sleep for the wicked
you